okay boys okay girls it's time to play
episode at 3:00 okay I'm very excited
about this this is the kind of the one
that people were like it's gonna come
well actually we were like well
searching for a place to call home
AJ and I found an old boarding school
run by kids deep in the forest there was
a guy named Marlin total and agent
pulled the trigger
I told AJ he was justified for killing
him the other kids didn't see it that
way they voted to kick us out I thought
we'd never return then AJ and I were
attacked by Abel one of the Raiders
Marlin had given the twins to he was
with someone I thought I'd never see
again
suddenly one of them spoke to me his
name was James an ex whisper who didn't
believe in killing walkers real medicine
he wouldn't make it the kids didn't turn
away the sad sight of AJ and led us back
inside after I told them how we could
defend the school against the Raiders
they were willing to let us stay at
least until the fight I decided to help
violet in the bell tower we looked at
the stars together and I admitted I had
feelings for her planned until 10 ran
out of cover hoping for a chance to
learn about his missing sisters the bomb
went off and attempting to save 10 Mitch
threw himself at Lilly and got a knife
to the throat with only a second to
decide
I fired and saved violet they got away
with three of our friends and we had no
idea where they'd gone someone who did
oh my god the edge' it's the whether
it's the weather
oh yeah I tell you that
like match why she's upset about it but
I got it again I guess nice to me I
promise you Willie the people who did
this we're going to hit them back Ted
never coming near us
that's right instead I think he'd find a
way to hang these brains out with a rock
Hey
AJ's waiting for you in the basement we
got anything tied up tight he's alive
but he's out cold
Thanks
we should bury Mitch it's time
just over the pile with the rest ten
I'll take care of this talk to Abel find
out where Lily took Lewis Omar in a sim
and Clem don't be afraid to you know
hurt him a little
maybe you'll get more out of him than me
oh this is gonna be good okay okay
let's have fought me that's the wall
where that person [ __ ] Barlet Myrna
that other person [ __ ] link that's
just - oh my god baby look Dennis Oh any
girl memorabilia real quick I can thank
you jack let's say I take this for the
wall or something yeah we'll take that
for a bedroom that's cool we just go
[ __ ] take property only [ __ ] hey
should be strong enough to hold him
perfect fact if he has an air blocked in
that block
[ __ ] she's getting everything right
and they started job did [ __ ] MVP
okay one sec before we go over there is
there a captain over here right now
[ __ ] you guys going nuts uh-huh
well don't want Debs it's different like
this
well them all broken but I still hate
them ready Abel you're gonna learn and
with AJ here learn some new [ __ ] right
now Jim
it stretches [ __ ] [ __ ] afternoon I was
having a nice dream too about a girl I
used to know
it's sad that for smack up a prisoner if
you get my meaning go back to my dream
oh yeah it's good the broken parts I
don't like your voice
first thing you learn [ __ ] you oh I give
a [ __ ] don't make this harder than it
needs to be okay I just want to know
where Lily took my people it doesn't
matter as soon as she gets there she's
gonna turn around and come right back
for me you had to give me the five-star
treatment if I'm smiling when she gets
here you might be able to tell us where
they took our friends or she'll do it
again
three sprouts can barely hold a gun even
tell me like me can do the math on that
one we're gonna get him back we're gonna
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that's like out there
it's a bloodbath one community against
another from Richmond to the coast back
in the Delta World War with some really
sick [ __ ] who make me look like the
Virgin Mary we need people to fight it
thank you mad at me you think we like
doing raids like this it's a good home
built to last
I do a lot to protect it
maybe you can understand that thank you
a lot to get my friends back so stop
wasting my time
tell me [ __ ] okay front pocket I
answered all your questions
read it uh so ever parted the hoof and
his clovenfooted and she with the cud
among the beasts that shall ye eat [ __ ]
is this code no it's [ __ ] Leviticus I
was hoping it'd be some timely
moralistic [ __ ] about turning the other
cheek well c'mon light itself I don't
know where your friends are ok [ __ ]
help me remember stuff I hope so
and I hope he suffers every moment till
he does that's a cold
Shh I know things doing like this
everything [ __ ] only turn No
my whole life everything I ever got I
got with my own two hands and my will
the dirt on me did they control I'll
tell you where to find lily
pick up real fast how about this how
about you tell me everything you know
and then we'll see I need assurances as
good as you're gonna get hurry up Abel
you don't have much time you wouldn't do
things try me
I really don't care
this isn't about your pain we want
answers
tell me [ __ ] you're still in there when
you turn I'll keep asking until you talk
a walker can talk
this one will oh [ __ ] that is some cold
ash a daddy some call that shampoo
you'll find a paper with everything you
need to know
check his boot only when we use these
days is rocking
he's kind of a [ __ ] anything
[Music]
Oh
holy [ __ ]
you don't need to watch this yeah I'd
like to watch this bro
I want to okay
I can sleep out there
yeah Abel is he still in there come on
we have a boat to find what the [ __ ]
Wow this fence ain't [ __ ] how does some
insane [ __ ] way I got them and she's
gonna be a tough boy okay then that
means together we got rid of their music
tow the tow check it is okay okay we're
chose a nice muchachos a nice crime yeah
you get kind of [ __ ] up there maybe
you should have been there maybe here
maybe it's best he stayed upstairs for
that but yeah it's kind of like it you
know yeah it's kind of like Shelley at
the end of the movie the purge my gosh
you should not all of them lunch at you
know like a flower that's nice hope it
doesn't turn okay here I go
episode 3 episode 3
he's like whoa
it looks scary [ __ ] scarecrow nobody
knows the same way to sneak on board
yeah doesn't [ __ ] it up this time it
wasn't since fall
yes it was Mitch died because they one
more thing about Tim
I'm dare you guys look [ __ ] there baby
what the [ __ ] did they bring the kids
listen on again wait how do you thoughts
are left like that's [ __ ] it cuz
Mitch and Lewis were like the second
biggest guys I don't care whether new
bring yeah I guess you just all the boys
I guess that is it the beach [ __ ] Wood
Street in the water
that's called up here hmm Pierre okay
let's spread out and focus on those
areas keep your heads low look at these
[ __ ] and they collectibles they're
collectibles I said I'm here for you no
I want the collectibles thank you sorry
I click those
have you ever seen this boat before no
Marlin kept us confined to the safe zone
pier leading up to the boat it's our
only way in and out well what else is
down there that's you on deck couple
others on the pier could be more inside
looks like they're well-armed too
[ __ ] how do you get a chance to look at
anything through there never look there
more yeah okay finally wait I see Luis
Abel was when I stood dumped in that far
away okay now I can actually luck it's
it's something SS something Gerald is
expect I'll expect entrance examined
Pierre look at path okay there's no good
cover leading up to the boat we're gonna
need one hell of a distraction
well what's that oh it's they got took a
quiet gonna prop out sick maybe if we
could get Walker's on the beach somehow
maybe not as hard as you do rock over
there actually we're fighting the same
one over make any noise the pier has
plenty of cover on it if we're careful
we can sneak in undetected
I can see an entrance I saw that too
it looks like there's a door at the
other end there's a small opening at the
top of those clothes doorways okay and I
know how to deal with those mm-hmm B
small B small manager says I don't see
any obvious place to keep prisoners
they're probably below deck we should
have asked Abel and he said on a boat I
didn't think you'd be this big [ __ ]
oh I so venire a rabbit's foot
what more used to carry about a rabbit's
foot you don't think I'll take it home
you can give it back to him once we've
saved him it's a bit better because he's
[ __ ] dead
anything useful looks like building
material furniture probably stuff from
the train station and look around real
quick hey when you click one thing and
it ends your [ __ ] [ __ ] session that
touches ok
are those tortious maybe why we could
use the fire you think about that's
dangerous she would quite a bit of it
should have that stop yeah yes that's it
I'm saying they're loading those wraps
with supplies I could put those loose
and just write them down River easy
they cut them loose in that way
downriver find anything over here they
have roses
let me see March would you switches
setting the hay on fire would get their
attention scared the horses too we could
get on the boat easier that way yeah
yeah yeah I think so I think that if we
cut those horses free we could slow down
anyone trying to chase us we got a lot
to do we got a lot to do before they
spot us we can talk to the plan once
we're somewhere safe
what's the plan
they've got guards posted on the pier
and the boat there's no way we can take
them all at once
my only hope is to distract them while
we sneak on board we should burn their
stuff [ __ ]
bad work we could burn the supplies or
the hay they keep for the horses
whatever we don't burn we should take
the horses but I'd rather steal those
supplies yeah we'll steal their supplies
and burn the hay is our distraction if
you're going to steal from the rafts you
have to do it carefully wouldn't do it
any other way
good catch fire where the Raiders away
from the boat and we can sneak across
the pier if anyone sees us yeah they
will
hey well you remember that guy I told
you about James he sent in walkers to
save us from Lilly and Abel maybe we
could convince him to do it again onto
the beach you can blend in without being
seen
your second shoot you if there's enough
time you get James perfect what about
after we get everyone home I mean you
just come attack us again hide quick
yes we're all here for that look at him
and the [ __ ] is that
a Raider has to be you all stay here
I'll see if they know anything that
could help us
good good we've duct tape too so we can
[ __ ] sound some drop it drop that
[ __ ] how many of you are there
how many of who I'm not [ __ ] around
answer the question
8'o that's Manny oh my god
after the attack I wasn't sure I mean I
heard they burned half your school down
who survived Ruby Mitch Brodie Ruby and
10 made it didn't ya Dan's boots holding
up okay
so old they're more holes in rubber
I got taped him up the last time I saw
him but that was a while ago
these boots are fine your Clementine the
girl who took over after Marlon died huh
it's weird
I thought everyone would want to lean on
their own violets the one in charge
really the violet I knew could barely
stand to talk to people let alone play
class president why she like a [ __ ] you
were the one who convinced the school to
fight back from where I'm standing
that puts you in charge your leadership
is going to get my little brother killed
excuse me people figured he could talk
Marlon into handing everyone over like
he and Lily did like they did before
ruined
he gave me one Sophie away yeah and we
all survived it Merlin would have never
made them fight the way you did he
wouldn't have gotten people killed
meanie you're wrong
clan protected us he wouldn't have
gotten people killed
he murdered Brodie what yeah helping
where's Sophie she alive she she died
protecting the Delta zero five zero
Rockingham finish up and head back I
want to be in before dark
another that's a shot yes ma'am
she could be a little eerie why he takes
off I cannot answer
our boat leaves for the Delta in two
days then it'll be a couple of weeks
before we can come back for the rest of
you hmm when we do don't fight the only
way you're gonna save your people is to
let us take them don't have ten could
see you now Timmy I said be ashamed to
call you his sister ooh that hurt
[ __ ] hurt
are you okay
nothing's changed our plan is to get
onto the boat and save our friends so
that's what we're gonna do okay okay if
they start getting things ready get
everyone caught up on the plan
everyone except ten I warned you enough
both of you
go find James
good luck fighting ahead James there's a
lone [ __ ] data that what
so how many walkers do you think James
will help us get 1500 a thousand it
feels like someone pinched me from
inside here let's rest a second
it's happy way man
I keep thinking
when Willie said all that stuff about
ten before I got so mad he was being
mean ten wasn't even there to defend
himself uh-huh
I wanted to hurt him I know I shouldn't
but just can't stop thinking about it
I wouldn't just punch his head it's okay
to get mad at people you can't help that
but those thoughts have to stay in your
head okay don't act on them bottle up
your anger like the rest of man Society
I'm strong I can control what I do but
not what I think like I think I think
I'm mad at tend to that's why we're
sending him first
the kids know all the stuff we know and
there's a plan you have to follow it
just makes them not listen no the other
kids haven't had it as hard as we've had
we had to make a lot of mistakes to
learn what we know mistakes are just so
bad it's because half his brain was
blown away for them to like we did it's
weird that people are so different it is
Erikson's boarding school for troubled
youth trouble like that so they did bad
things
okay sometimes they do them because bad
things happened to them I knew a doctor
once back when you were just a baby
he called it trauma you have some too
you know the thing where people can't
walk up behind you I don't like my
trauma I want to get it off of me
I don't even like the way the word
sounds it's really really hard to do by
yourself a lot of people can't without
some help like from a doctor I'm not
sure but those are rare these days or
like the school right it was supposed to
help with people's trauma
yeah it was and now they help each other
mm-hm I still like them I liked in the
most I think even if he does dumb things
because he doesn't really dumb things I
think he's my first real friend oh yeah
I thought I was your first real friend
yeah you don't count your old I am NOT
fine he's my second folks real friend
okay
I'm gonna how we gotta find out what Jan
says look what it is thing I hear like
somebody talking right now doesn't miss
a lot time that's the can probably just
like [ __ ] sitting there
I don't see James just monsters is that
gonna happen
where's your mess [ __ ] yeah did the
Raiders do this it looked like they had
people from your school why are you here
those people you saw we're going to save
them but to do that we need your help
moving some walkers
oh no not here friends maybe help but my
mask is still in the camp inside my back
I can't pass through a herd without it
then I got ok let's go get it
I just asked that you don't kill them
the walkers if you distract him I can
sneak over and find my mask destroy all
of them brats
oh I'll try ok we give this stumbo now
can we just press eat you but I can
there we go
holy [ __ ]
is that although did you find your mask
really crying that you're gonna get that
Maspero push it the noise will draw them
away did he not pick up everything just
now yes that [ __ ]
a separate batch
hey Jay are you okay yeah no bites hmm I
did spare them didn't I would have been
easier to kill them
your kind I appreciate it really
Marcy that's disgusting
thank you for helping me get this back
no I will Walker save your friends
they're being held captive on a boat not
too far from here we can't sneak on
board without cover
not without the Raiders gunning us down
so a hide to sneak on board their ship
that's insane
it's our only chance
I have something I need you to see happy
you happy [ __ ] disgusting we still
need this help right yeah we do
it's safe okay
just a little further
what is it
I figure that what the [ __ ] is that do
the power say sure tonight
no there's definitely a tours of new
yorkese it's Decker in my place where is
it
where is the toy it's like a farm or
something
Salt Lake
what's this it's called a Salt Lake it's
a solid you just kind of like yeah
what's then yeah I like that
Salt Lake sounds gross leave it alone
okay why is something wrong with it
no that's a sources bad memories kiddo
wait seriously
hmm okay really are you horse Ponce oh I
gotta fix this thing [ __ ] Mouse
didn't like appropriately get captured
not going in yeah until I get my [ __ ]
memorabilia where is it what am i
keeping a toy perfect
give her here I knew it'd be mine
beatnik
my people my former people they had a
practice they called it collecting
[ __ ] thieves what the [ __ ] they use
them as a weapon I do this to protect
them I know it sounds strange but that's
why I brought you here to see them as I
do as people the [ __ ] jazz people well
not people exactly but something in
between
deep down so few of us die anymore we
turn not dead not alive I wish I could
see it that way it'd be nice to think
that everyone isn't actually gone
[ __ ] God in a way they're just lost
no they're [ __ ] dead do you really
think there's people inside of monsters
somewhere yes
think about it this way as someone you
cared about turned no Klum's friend we
she shot him before he did so he
wouldn't have to suffer sorry maybe this
wasn't the best way to explain didn't
mean to bring up difficult memories
right yeah dead soon hats house and walk
even years still do in a way when
they're alone
was innocent if you want my help I need
you to try and walk with them and tell
me if you really believe they're just
monsters they are just monsters they're
not people or friends Klim she wore them
I promise this isn't smart it's too
dangerous
Louis would do it for us Louis again yes
the first rule is never go alone I'm not
leaving you
I'll be right back check the windows I
will say [ __ ] off to fear yes why
managing the mask will disguise your
scent but be gentle and be quiet touch
the wind chime you'll see let me touch
the witcher actually let me think he
went in there that [ __ ] okay so I just
kind of yeah in my way horse yeah
he's like hey [ __ ] a second scary
actually can I just push them that was
disgusting anyway I'm just kind of got
touch-up
they're like what is that they're
[ __ ] disgusting
ah
hey sexy way
whoa hey there kiddo all right I'm fine
see no bites no bite
so do you still think they're just
monsters yeah they're [ __ ] monsters
that you've seen them at peace yeah I do
there's still just monsters there's
things that want to kill us says it what
I thought you would say it's what I
would have said too many have you ever
killed a person Manny Wow holy [ __ ] that
was a long time ago I've killed someone
before - AJ you've killed someone
yeah but I was justified that's enough
what about the walkers are you going to
help us save our friends I thought I
could but I can't so many walkers would
die
oh the death this would cost I'm sorry
Clementine I can't have more blood on my
hands
please or my friends are gonna die I've
never had any before I came here I can't
let them
[Music]
I may be stubborn but I'm not heartless
Samantha yes those Raiders are cruel
they force others to be the same and
even if your friends think like you no
one deserves that yeah it'll take some
time to guide them through the force to
the shore others will join the herd as
they go miss nice day tomorrow night
be ready I can't undo this way Wow a
disgusting
I can disgusting
once a [ __ ] huge Cavs Wow come on AJ
let's get back before it's too dark
okay all right I've never met anyone
like James before not like you though he
doesn't kill monsters but he's not
scared of them either he's cool
okay hey Clem Willie told me the plan
how'd things go with that guy James he
agreed to help us if somebody told me we
were gonna sneak onto a boat and I heard
a Walker's had called them crazy
yeah oh I wanted to throw one last hit
nanny before the big fight
swear huh it sounds like a swear what
the hell is a hootenanny it's just
another way of saying party yeah I know
it sounds strange don't a party but
people need something to lift their
spirits right about now yeah I wouldn't
make some tea for everyone can I borrow
your little heater thing what can I do
we need to pretty up the old music room
could you make us something colorful to
hang up okay I'll be an artist how are
you still awake
I know [ __ ] that's bad but like
seriously like I'm gonna make the deck
there's there's like not nearly as much
I like decoration stuff right I guess
all things in glass or like how did the
heater because of all the preserves and
[ __ ] I still eat Twinkies okay you draw
pictures like this cool
right upright again right a potato
something
yeah perhaps over there pride put the
grab the foot in there right now
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] is that
yeah they're for luck are bunnies lucky
just their feet what's his name beatnik
that's fun
do you even care what the joke is okay
okay it's good [ __ ] out of here
you gonna talk to him hey you're getting
better at this soon you'll be as good an
artist as 10 I don't know he's really
good something wrong he's taking
remember how come he is aging I was just
thinking about stuff while I was drawing
I don't think I should have watched Abel
turn into a monster clue I know I axed
it gave me a sore throat yeah yeah what
do you mean I don't know like swallowing
was hard sounds weird but it happened he
was a bad guy I know I shouldn't feel
like this I hated him too I think
there's something wrong with me you know
what AJ everything you're feeling is
okay it makes you a good person uh-huh
am I good
I wish what we did felt good partner he
wants to like it I'm getting real smart
because I'm always thinking all the time
okay what are you thinking about right
now
you getting bit turning into a monster
ain't gonna have my breath yeah the
older I get the more I see you don't
know why what happens then anyone can
get bit that's not happening you don't
know no bro no I don't but it won't
happen anytime soon
you don't know that either you're just
trying to be brave for me it does
something weird to my stomach like I'm
gonna get the doobies okay I need to
know you remember what we talked about
what you're supposed to do if it happens
listen to me if I get bit
you'll
run away run away as fast as no no I'm
not gonna do that
hey Jay you prize don't care I'm not
leaving you if you get this I'd want you
to bite me too what you don't mean that
gonna be alone what the [ __ ]
please don't be mad I can't live with
you not with me Clem I know we've talked
about it so much don't make me Alvin jr.
you know you're not supposed to talk
like this you're too strong and too
brave I don't think I am anymore
about this yes you are you are okay
you can't break promises AJ no I'm not
letting this go are you
James said they would be around for
monsters like on the inside
maybe we'd still be together
no just be a different together not Brad
that's crazy get back James gonna be
okay James said a lot of things about
the monsters and most of it was crazy
pants AJ so you don't think I would be
inside my monster yourself yeah there is
no monster self kiddo nothing that makes
you you would be in there
can I go patrol for a bit before the
party sure go ahead
be careful
[ __ ] what's with AJ he just needs some
space
can we talk about what happened today
with mini-course baby what's wrong
the thing is seeing mini I feel like it
should have scared me but it didn't
person we ran into in the woods that
wasn't many not really the way she
sounded acted the way she talked about
Sophie and Lily I'm confused I guess we
can still save Minnie
if we brought her back we could you saw
how she reacted when Lily showed up
those are her people you're not the real
Minnie she's gone
she's been gone this whole time and I I
have to stop warning her I won't let her
take you or AJ or anyone else I care
about Lewis knows when to keep his head
down yeah well I hope so you know when I
first got here I hated him so much you
know it's like look at me watch me
perform it's so stupid
mm-hmm then I realized under all that he
he really cares about people and he
doesn't just feel it he says it I'll
tell you every goddamn day how much you
need them [ __ ] he'll probably sing about
it especially if there's already a
famous song with your name in it we've
got to get him back we will Louis Omar
SM he'll get them all back yeah we're
good
I made you this don't [ __ ] that
little slice of lemon
ah [ __ ] you make this pretty good I
never will
when you told me you had feelings for me
I was shocked then I started thinking
there's something I've always wanted to
try with someone I cared about and I
never have what what is it have you ever
danced with anyone before
nope do you like that lay down we're
dancin get him me to the music
thanks for the dance yeah we're getting
better at being romantic yeah
holy [ __ ] did I catch that Wow
where did you find a beach ball it was
in some garbage behind one of the dorm I
had to blow it up and that was pretty
gross but look it works I should get
going
maybe he could probably use some help
it's cool right super cool these guys
[ __ ] Stoke you're terrible Hey
I love you khlo I love you back kiddo
ah okay we better get ready to go sounds
like they need us in the music room okay
so I can say I'm actually too critical
dog is second gather yeah we still need
to figure out lighting music and
something to write on that banner if
we're gonna die we should have some fun
first
music good Lewis isn't here see that
tents like Lewis in a box hold out the
old Headmaster's gramophone so I could
play some records not much of a
selection but Jess should do wouldn't
happen to have any good jazz records
would you oh yeah the old music teacher
it was a big fan pretty cool guy up
until he ditched us all what's jazz
sound like that one's hard to describe
just waiting on her face that's for you
so you take one of those Rock things
that wouldn't be a party without some
kind of mood lighting I've been going
back and forth between colors for ages
purple really is calming but purple
might be nice hmmm well purple was my
dad's favorite color okay all right
somewhere purple was a color of royalty
purple really what I like purple
shouldn't you like it too violet that's
why I picked that I'll make it happen
are we using the banner for some kind of
party theme mm-hmm not exactly it's
meant to be more motivational I'd keep
it short though it's not as much room as
you think I was thinking something
uplifting like we're gonna get through
this
AJ why don't you come up with something
really I have an idea it'll be a
surprise okay I promised not to swear
all over it okay we'll have 10 break out
his paintbrush and write it out this is
a ten tell me I'm gonna look great
yeah I'm set up there
first ever oh and Willie was asking for
you
he's up in Marlins office said he had a
surprise for the party but he wanted to
show it to you first
too bad you're not actually gonna hear
jeana's cuz i'm you to that music
that's all I gonna say I'm here today
hey Clem I found a bunch of books on
ships there's some awesome stuff about
fires at sea and explosions and stuff
he is the boiler wait what are you
talking about I have an idea about how
to stop those [ __ ] coming back to
the school after we've rescued the
others and from hurting anyone else ever
again
perfect we're gonna blow up the boat
besides it feels right you know that's
right our prayer Mitch nice Mitch would
love this plan I know it's perfect I
can't think of a better Memorial than to
blow that boat out of the water the
tricky bit is timing the explosions so
that it happens after you get off the
boat we'll be okay
transistor Willie but music Clinton I'm
sorry for before Wade lied on their
faces see this what is that I know it's
not his fault
that's nice Willie but don't tell me
tell 10
yeah I once a baby
my dog is huge
wow this looks great Ruby
Edna done it without you surprise that
means just wait to see what else I've
got planned go ahead and mingle I'll let
you know when it's time the [ __ ] I guess
I see you two are working together yeah
Willy asked me to help with his special
project well that's good to hear
is it ready good to go Clem it'll work
actually ah I was thinking maybe we
should name it something cool yeah we
absolutely have to name it
I thought you make fun of me but hell
yeah
what's name is [ __ ]
this is mr. B's Mitch's masterpiece yeah
I like that Mitch would have to okay
then it's settled
I found them okay Clementine these here
are our official Erickson psych
evaluations and probationary oh my god
okay I don't get
well these explain why all of us got
sent to this school in the first place
you know the bad [ __ ] we did that kept
them from sending us back home so what's
the game I figured if we're all going on
this crazy mission together might as
well know who we really are
yeah I'll read some of what the adults
thought about us and you have to guess
which one of us fits the bill I'll make
sure it's someone you've actually met
this will be the first one while
otherwise a remarkable student Blanc
continues to be plagued by fits of anger
uncontrollable cursing and repeated
physical altercations with the senior
faculty that's a thick the kid Varla oh
not to speak ill of the dead but that
sounds exactly like Marlon you'd think
so but no really
the person in the file imagine Marlon
times another serious guilty as charged
holy [ __ ] yeah you should have seen Ruby
back in the early days she was like you
ever seen those Tasmanian Devil cartoons
in New York kid that was our Ruby he
used to have a mean streak a mile long
don't worry
that was a long time ago I mean I can
totally see it the first time I met Ruby
she was all that little [ __ ]
sounds cursing sorry you guys wouldn't
know why I got in here Willy please no
masturbation what trust me
nobody wanted to know what what does
that mean ah
don't you dare
uh anyway maybe we should change up the
music like all kind of different music I
think there's a lot of them how many I
don't know a lot sure we've heard enough
of this put on the classical stuff
I see upset I didn't realize how many of
us we lost
remember that Justin guy and Thaurissan
and Jasper that one girl with colored
braces and Joey Maddy
Lamar Aaron yeah I used to make fun of
her braces why did I do that
max do we Trey
Stephanie holy crap how many of us died
34 [ __ ]
whose is it Lois should we read it I
could tell you why I was saying instead
you know as a consolation prize or
whatever yes you might hate me after but
since we're all being so open and all I
was hoping you'd tell me I spent a lot
of time at my grandma's house growing up
not with my dad being a drunk and my mom
working three jobs but after my grandpa
died grandma just kind of shut down I
spent all day and I rockin in her little
chair and then I'd sit there at her feet
as we both watch TV mostly cartoons
since she never seemed to care sometimes
I could hear her crying you know anyway
one day she left the den and came back
with another chair and 22 rifle set the
rifle butt on the top of the chair
holding the barrel back to her chest so
you know she had trouble reaching the
trigger this way but she wants to know
what happened
because she took out this really tacky
wooden back scratcher
the real long kind with the one end
shaped like a hand and use that to push
the jewelry okay so yeah bang right her
body folded up and just kept rocking my
mom came to get me five hours later I
hadn't moved she asked why I didn't call
the police or an ambulance or anything I
just shrugged and told her it wasn't
like grandma was going anywhere besides
I just wanted to finish my cartoons
anyways this is it another CD we could
put in the in the player she shipped me
off to Eric's in the next day that's the
weather you think tomorrow so sorry
violet that was my food this party he
went through it's fine
we've just been through a lot of [ __ ] we
weren't good people I mean time but it
still doesn't mean that we should have
been left here to die by the people that
we're supposed to take care of us sorry
this is supposed to be fun um I'm just
not the game tied like I guess you mean
is we'll see them soon hey I've got an
idea have a stretch guys remember when
Minnie would sing us don't be afraid
when all of us used to get scared too
bad I can't play it we would have known
her he liked that one
Janice
like she used to your voice is really
pretty oh my god okay
okay yeah all right I I can do that
Jenny said
[Music]
yeah where you go it's a musical now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
knightly achievement it's cool yeah
trainer so what's going on there's just
about oh my god what a throwback
I forgot you wear that outfit
no way
hey sweet pea
no way
why the Train always pick the train
I'm not sure maybe because this is where
it all started
are you taught me to shoot and to cut my
hair to be ready for what was coming you
were a quick study so what's on your
mind this time
worriedly I've got a lot of people
depending on me and I don't know if what
I'm doing is right oh I know that
feeling
you know I was making it all up as I
went along right
couldn't let on of course I never
noticed it just felt like you always
knew the right thing to do well I got
lucky
what counts for a lot you want to tell
me about what you're up against I've
been in so many and they always fall
apart I really like this one it's
different
it almost feels like home that's a good
thing
Todd being alone out there well we're in
trouble
some bad people captured my friends and
getting them back might get the rest of
us killed
I'm not worried
what whatever trouble you in you get out
of it you'll get your friends out of it
you don't know I know you are survivor
Clementine I know what's gonna fix it
you're right
I just needed to hear you say I'm going
to get my friends out of this every one
of them alive that's right Lois is gonna
say when he sees your face those boys
are gonna have hope again knowing that
you came to rescue oh sweet pea you know
you always get like this before
something big remember how scared you
were before you charged into that mess
of McCarroll branch you survived that
didn't you
I know it's harder when you have
something to lose but having people you
care about
that's a good thing mm-hmm friends the
girl who loves how he doesn't talk about
how she tortured that guy beside you
because of you
come see me again when you've gotten
them out okay out and safe
sound good and hopefully we can talk
about happier things
I wish you were really here I miss you
too Clementine
but we'll have to make do with
pretending
Thank You Lee talking you always makes
me feel a little bit better he's got
some good fitted clothes that's all I
gotta say I meant to ask how's the boy
he's good Lee you'd like him you teach
him to shoot yet you have no idea I
guess the world got pretty hard since I
left in it
kid growing up in it he'd be hard to
you're in my shoes now raising the kid I
think you got a handle on it
mm-hmm can't be easy willing to give him
a childhood but knowing what it takes to
survive now time to be strong and brave
and capable he'd be so proud
Shane's back yes she stole me
Wow just look at you just look at you
this group you like I better not live in
a city you know I told you to avoid
those they don't no one goes into the
cities anymore it's an old boarding
school in the woods miles from anywhere
with no adults at all no adults it works
I promise
time to go gluten time
you've got people that need you
goodbye Lee
Klim wake up it's time to go
we got a long walk
mm-hm
yesterday hey Gabby Oh oh my god that's
oh my goodness that is disgusting what
I'm solid yes we're really doing this
discuss only the team blending in with
the walkers need to cover themselves now
we just need your walker friend is here
good lord
hello hey guys this is James he's my
friend yeah it's cool guy he's you get
the skin like that
Oh Clementine can I try it on
that's not a good come on give him some
space I just wanted not right now yeah
yeah oh sorry I tried to shoot at one
time your mask looks so real I hey hey
there James hurry about Willie is this
the guy that clue said she'd marry
holy [ __ ] yeah um Clementine could I
speak to you alone for a moment
good idea hold tight hey thank you come
talk for a sec there's something I have
to tell you didn't [ __ ] the walkers
they'll be here in a little while you
can join them as they pass through the
trees noise from the boat will draw them
toward the water and we can get on board
and save our friends
yeah our friends are different
open-minded accepting listen Clementine
I need to talk to you about AJ what what
do you mean
the whispers or my family from a young
age in that time I witnessed a lot of
death and suffering eventually I became
the cause of it
okay this was considered a poison and I
believed in that fiercely so much so
that when another boy expressed sympathy
for our enemy before an attack I slit
his throat dr. buck didn't consider who
he was why he felt honestly I don't even
remember his name that's that's kind of
hard to believe
it doesn't sound anything like you not
anymore but it was I had no doubt in my
mind that I was right after he died I
kept hearing his words in my head
those people are like us just on a
different path
I stopped killing after that I changed
no one else did when AJ told me he
killed someone it reminded me of them
myself you know you tell me
let it be apparent so from a young age
it breaks something inside you
I just I'm afraid if AJ kills again he
won't be able to go back okay he won't
be the same boy he was I'm not going to
let AJ become a killer I don't want him
to change not like that I hope you can
keep that promise
are you telling me that'll raise your
kids soon there will be enough of me to
provide us cover I'll lead you through
the hurt until you reach the boat that's
as far as I go after that it's up to you
okay thank you thank you text inmate
enemies Evan take care of AJ
okay he's ready to go the walkers are
getting close
Ruby you're in charge of the horses well
like dad take care of the supplies I've
got the bomb
he says find the boiler there'll be a
door on the bottom with ash and stuff
put it in there okay let's do this my
precious
see you all on the other side uh-huh
we'll do this
finally told me about many that so if he
died and Minnie is one of them then just
did you see your other tell her tell her
I forgive her okay
please I tell her myself but I just
wanted to be okay yeah sure if we see
her I'll let her know
Thanks okay it's interesting
violet you cheated a man you meet you
today
hey it's time we got a move
Glenn what happens if someone else gets
caught while we're in there what if it's
you I couldn't save Minnie or Lewis and
Omar I I really care about you Clem if
something happened to you because of me
you'd feel pretty bad I can't lose you
too okay
oh that's how they know you better not
disappear on me okay I promise what are
you doing go look in another direction
are we good yeah I think so
okay let's bring our friends back home
all of them
let's do this let's do this my chouchou
it's ready def 5 I know this is gonna
sound gross why bring yourself spark
at least don't put on the baseball hat
you know it's not a lot of washers out
here so like he throwing those clothes
out my back about that
Thanks
you're gonna do it
we're doing new west side going to east
side of it
[Music]
okay
here we go
that is freaking hard
cut cut cut
yeah Kim Kim Kim Kim Kim uh suck it hard
there's a good that there's a Cadillac
okay
okay I'm just sticking on this one
I made I make [ __ ] [ __ ]
stay behind the walkers use them as
shields I think I'm just like running
too much behind them
okay okay
fucking's let me get behind one of these
[ __ ]
and dad [ __ ] head
stay behind the walkers use them as
shields
[ __ ] stay behind the walkers use them as
shields
okay
holy [ __ ] okay we made it great did it
right that it that's [ __ ] hard holy
[ __ ]
now that one's gonna death okay yes yes
we can't risk leaving cover but we'll
have to call along the side of the dock
okay
okay I'm walking I'm walking
the gods are watching
citizens coming this bets
I understand the hell away from Matt's
all I can say this way oh that's so cool
wow that's a memorable moment
I guess they're my batch
okay I'm fine
stay close okay okay let's go
okay I guess we could go
come on let's hurry
ready AJ and knowing that I can see the
sending out on that side yeah [ __ ]
because it's ready beer behind me [ __ ]
I got that he got me second set
come on let's hurry don't touch your
girl watches cutscene ready AJ walkers
who says that like before they even look
[ __ ] slow
Oh
so [ __ ] out edit you got this one a
lot of editing we're getting close after
we find the boiler and place the bomb
we'll get our friends out nanny said
there were eight Raiders but we didn't
see that many outside look out for
guards and stay quite okay yeah good
I'll go ahead and signal when it's clear
got it
can I help you ma'am I'm looking for
collectibles scratching his wound okay
they can't sticking your outside did
Rockingham I'm looking around in the
dark and get back to your that's that
that's where we need to plant the bomb
there's too much stuff in the way
I think clothes killed anyone to take me
not at the zombie wait here I don't
recall a single time
oh [ __ ]
there we go there you go
Mitch's masterpiece once they start up
this boat we won't have much time before
it explodes
how long not sure an hour 30 minutes
let's hurry up then find your friends
okay and there there's Lois she's like
that's annoying once I just got to be a
car in here somewhere
Minerva focus
I have a little brother short scarred
piece see he's not out there is he look
we've discussed this
your family is Delta now well she's
tough
Delta of course she had to be the
Celgard
we can't sneak past her should I like
get out without our people God you got
10 caught up in this just just tell me
that he's safe he says yeah me that he
told me to tell you he forgives you
I'll help you get everyone out then you
take my brother and run get him back to
where it's safe come on we have to hurry
well better do this oh my god are you
okay dad look her I yeah I'm all right
we're all right
take care of Lewis first he's he's in
rough shape yes I can find Lewis we
gonna go you don't have a lot of time
before Doreen comes back
violent help me with these guys got it
Louis yeah how is that a good Jess ain't
a good
all right that says thank God but not my
worst time like waking up in a workplace
Lois
okay what did they do to you serious
time I weren't you that you're annoying
it's okay hmm okay
I warned you he just had a kids are too
dense you he'll be home soon
Oh get the [ __ ] out of here that always
stuck in a cell [ __ ] Louis you and
that time you sex still annoying cuz I'm
happen we're not staying here that long
anything else in here second as [ __ ] in
his best my talking allows he's [ __ ]
on let's say here he can't looks like
there's a gap here perfect my hand
through leverage Clem
are you alright I'm fine where's AJ
over here thank God
hey guys still got time to figure this
out
let's get the [ __ ] out of here thank ya
anything can use the fryer over the door
I open the door I think I took this
[ __ ]
I'll get us out of here I promise that's
not the most enjoyable conversation I
have with this guy yet thank you
that's right there yeah route you go
with that [ __ ] I got the same one of my
sad I might be able to chip away at this
if I had a tool you have taken away my
knife AJ do you still have your knife
yeah they didn't find it only the big
one good good I need you to slide it
over to me perfect
good slide it slide where to go oh my
god actually got [ __ ] that's some funny
[ __ ] tower Louis I already cut her it's
like I'm not coming anymore
don't I promise you it ain't worth it
step back she awake yes ma'am I'll take
it from here
where is Abel he got hurt bad in the
fight we let him turn he wanted to die
quick but we didn't let him hable wasn't
so much pain from the fall he begged for
us to kill him he wasn't pretty
that's enough Minerva open the door yes
ma'am
there you go normally the trouble you
caused I'd shoot you and toss you
overboard but I'm genuinely impressed
okay first you organize these idiot kids
into a fighting force and kill two of my
most experienced soldiers then you sneak
onto my boat under the cover of a herd I
bring a prize like you back to the Delta
it might make this whole [ __ ] of
a mission worth it someone like you so
young with so much potential if I'm the
one you want let the others go this
isn't a negotiation this is me telling
you how things are going it's immediate
you know my father Larry was a military
man and when I was a kid he had the
thing that bugged him most was waste if
I ever left a light on it leaving a room
he'd flip no matter how many times he
ranted about the cost of electricity I
could never remember to hit that switch
okay so one day he let our power get cut
he liked illustrations to show that
actions have consequences
no more TV no more hairdryer no more
ice-cream sandwiches well I guess
[ __ ] runs in the family
is that the consequence that you're an
[ __ ] the consequence is I never left
the lights on again my father had his
faults but he showed me the
effectiveness of teaching by example oh
is that what this is a lesson
good the chef
I want to tell you a story let's call it
the parable of the twins two girls were
taken from their home and brought to a
new place to live they had to leave
their friends and family behind and that
was hard at first
they shed a lot of tears but the new
place was a good place the people there
grew corn and raised pigs and the twins
ate well for the first time in years
they had hot showers clean clothes beds
they were given guns and trained to use
them people there were kind to these
girls okay all that was asked in return
was that they helped defend the group
you see this place had a lot of enemies
killers and thieves who wanted what they
had they threatened to cut out their
tongues they only do that to the ones
who can't keep their mouths shut one of
the girls saw that this was a place
worth fighting for and her tears dried
but the other twin she could never
forget her old home every gift every
opportunity stirred up trouble every
chance she got she convinced her sister
to help her steal a raft and leave on
the river of course they didn't get far
what happened then Minerva
I killed her Minnie no tell me it's not
true your own sister why would you do
that hmm yeah why
she was twisting my head with her life
and I made a mistake I need it to show
my loyalty to the place I call home like
it or not about one of my people now
Clem the question is which twin are you
going to be the loyal one or the dead
one y'all better back away from the door
does the same thing kind of the reaction
I expected but you'll see I'm not
kidding around okay hold the mouthy one
out of the cell they clearly didn't get
the moral of the story we'll have to
help them understand
don't hurt violent or I'll hurt you hey
yo you better cool it oh you gonna get
yourself okay easy stay still
oh [ __ ] don't make this hurt more than
it has to
just breathe holy [ __ ] hey you got a
deserve to die well kill you you think
you can kill me I know I can well throw
you in the river but we'll tie you up
and watch you turn they talked for a
little guy hey stop
no I didn't do it I killed Marlon and I
was justified
thank ya yeah okay so you killed Marlon
I bet you to make a great soldier
don't hurt AJ I'll do whatever you want
Clem seems to care a lot about you come
on let's go have a chat just us AJ keep
an eye on her Minerva I want to be far
away from here that I'll start up the
boiler don't you dare look at me like
that it's the only way we survive who
are you
[ __ ] survival look at what you're doing
Minnie please I just want to talk to you
for a second
I'm sorry we never searched for you for
Sophie I'm sorry we trusted that [ __ ]
Marvin I know okay it's Sophie's dead I
have you all need to understand this is
the only way Jean line or you die the
people you love die you just do what
they say you can live
hey we got this press press Kim oh
that's cute I mean they won't get
snapped again we got on Buzz
get them off right get the hell out of
here define AJ better see you on land
you will get the crossbow star gonna
miss Debbie had to climb for her okay
sing
Shh they start the boiler see that come
walk here we go oh my god she'll go
you'll come around to once you see what
we have plenty of food comfortable beds
for you in Clem that's ten like that
worse Tim [ __ ] Tennessee did you get
lost
ma'am he wasn't alone James Oh Ruby this
way
that
found this in her
no wonder there were so many walkers
must have thought you were clever
leading those bankers here [ __ ] scammy
James would probably like the craziest
one no fun everybody force your ways
onto mothers because you're afraid
because you're weak I give my people a
cause to fight for the thing about
people like him aging community they
won't fight for anyone but themselves
okay
whoa ten easy birthday don't hurt him
just stop hurting people please shooter
why don't we all just take a breath all
right give me my friends back put down
the gun
let them go all of us or or else that
guy's gonna die okay instantly fine go
ahead then do it save your friend [ __ ]
that's what you came here to do isn't it
[ __ ]
oh I see you came here to cry - looks
like you're not a soldier
III don't know oh you got him I hate
like I'm great with timing perfect
accuracy and it doesn't the game doesn't
care like she ran the [ __ ] thanks jack
hi Chris [ __ ] a
yeah like that oh yeah got it
ooh that was your of dead like that oh
[ __ ] get that harder it baby you better
get it before I get it
hey that James that's head
that AJ she's not a threat
yes like that it's a trick
don't you dare bet that got down Brown
thought they got that right give me the
gun yeah anyone else
lower the gun a jade back up cuz I would
a dad okay she's gonna throw that knife
actually he's gonna get zapped now
goodbye James
Fred a glass that's her there wasn't
really a lot of room for James anyhow
Wow okay okay let's see we did 93% of
two in a row blah okay it's good let's
say mrs. masterpiece Wow
5% native AJ it's funny okay
8% allowed them but don't cut off your
friends figure in that way 56 too lazy
not to do it
hmm dang missing an action and this guy
turned
he'll fail she told him talking unit was
alcohol that's [ __ ] up grateful
grateful can't we sit down let's see
it's connection it helps when he swears
a little yeah
you knows what it is man to act touched
okay I think yes that's it then
oh wait any more
surprise
I see an actress in a can Ruby proud and
I recognize our official great who saved
that burgers is the MVP way that's
pretty cool actually
ah man wait I could have taken that Wow
okay
anyways thanks for watching everyone
that's good one excited for last one see
how I'm wrapped up and that much I know
there's a little bug but it's whatever
it's a game I'm sure they had the
roundup crew up for the once again kind
of thing and coders and they had rushed
I'm like so put back and I was QAS and
that pretty pretty good I kept getting
on all right well thank y'all for
watching thank you for watching see
y'all next